I kind of understood Men In Black a
little bit but I didn't want to make Men
In Black that was the next year after
Independence Day so I didn't want to
make two Alien movies back to back how
did they convince you
um Steven Spielberg sent a helicopter
for me
yeah
I was in New York to talk to me to talk
it like it landed at his house
and he had me a hello
well yeah you can't say no yeah yeah you
get off the helicopter at his house he
says come on and it was the first time
I'd ever had lemonade with carbonated
water
yeah you can't say yeah you can't say no
to that it was lemonade with carbonated
water and you had to act like you had
him yeah yeah yeah I was like this is
regular that's good [__] yeah
I would say that yeah it's a good [__]
Steve but yeah he flew me in and he he
said he said the coldest [__] he said
um he said tell me tell me why you don't
want to make my movie
and he was the producer and I was like
and he he put the ellipses at the end it
was the dot dot dot tell me why you
don't want to make my movie it was the
dot dot dot if he had continued he would
have said Joker you know I made Jaws
right yeah well you know I made E.T yeah
or [__] he might have said he
might well you know he's respected why
don't you want to make my move why you
don't want to make
a very low tone to it and I walked to
this house and he had the jobs poster
and the the was it with the um Jurassic
Park he had every so it was just so I
would know what's your answer what's my
answer and I was like you know I didn't
want to make two Alien movies back to
back I didn't want to go from
Independence Day to Men In Black you
know I felt like I would I didn't want
to be the alien guy was it but I mean
honestly it's a it's a worry that we
have because I think the the biggest
thing that we think about while having a
moment at the top is well how do you
stay at the top and I don't want to make
mistakes I definitely don't want to keep
doing the right thing I don't want to
think that this is the only thing I can
do I want to expand and do more so
absolutely I understand that logic I
understand why it would be worried
um I mean for him it's just basically
like I'm seeing a Spielberg and you're
protected yeah I don't make bad stuff
yeah and that goes back to one of the
one of the the earlier questions it's
like
it's a team sport
you know and
the there's a couple of really critical
things it's like who is at your right
hand like who your friends are who
you're with every day
um will make or break your dreams you
cannot build a
career and
um You probably I'm you know I'm going
to speak specifically from my experience
but you probably can't do much of
anything in this life at a high level
without a rock solid team and and you're
in your rise of it did you see that or
were you the individual that felt you
were doing it by yourself
now I never I never really thought I was
doing it by myself I knew that I had to
be the tip of the spear in terms of
discipline I knew I had to be the tip of
the spear in terms of Direction
um but but I always knew that I needed
my squad you know we've talked a lot
about
um you know our our parents absolutely
and you know my father was military so
it was very clear to me that there was a
commander so the commander is in charge
but if you ain't got nothing to command
nobody is willing to follow you you've
got nothing